hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again and
today we're gonna be talking about
blades of Persia the new for honour
crossover between for honor and Prince
of Persia but in more specific we're
gonna be talking about chapter two and
all the juicy stuff that's going to be
changing for the next chapter of this
event so as long as like the V if you do
enjoy subscribe barfi new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you wanna be kept today with everything
happening to the world of foreigner and
never miss out one or nothing definitely
subscribe the channel so with that let's
get started with today's video so real
quick Thank You Ubisoft for sponsoring
today's video if it wasn't for that then
I wouldn't be able to capture all this
early access footage for you guys and
today is March 18th it is a Wednesday
usually we meet up and do videos on
Thursdays but Ubisoft has allowed me to
upload this gameplay a day early so if
you're watching this video right when it
comes out or within 24 hours of its
release it is not in game yet and you
still have been the original chapter 1
content if it's past that 24 hour mark
then chapter 2 is live on all servers
for you now like I said obviously
chapter 1 it was the Prince of Persia
crossover blades of Persia you know
chapter 1 was last week and I rant down
everything in big detail in the videos
linked in the top right so definitely
check those out if you're uninformed if
those include weapons illustrious
outfits executions a new game mode and a
new free event battle pass with loads of
cool items in it I highly recommend you
check that out if you have no clue
what's going on or if you want a more
text version you can click the link down
in the description and you can visit it
there but today's topic is going to be
about chapter 2 and it got some changes
first up
arcade is still the same as well as the
customization options and the battle
pass so anything regarding that those
are gonna stay everything that changed
though has to do with the game mode the
first immediate changes a yeah on top of
that there's also in the new main menu
and faceoff music
and also on top of the faction map
there's a huge tornado like I'm talking
huge huge tornado but as for the biggest
reveal for the game mode its Wraith of
time instead of ruler of time now what
like I said this is going to go from
March 19 - April 2nd so for the next two
weeks starting tomorrow cos as I said
this video is going live on the 18th of
March it's a regular spin of ruler of
time except now the prince spawns with a
location on the map with the icon of a
dagger and also the spawn is a lot more
dark and gloomy and a dark tornado as
well as it the whole map itself just
being very dark and gloomy the prince is
still a guy what happens to teleport
with his tier 1 and then spear fate you
with the tier 4 right as soon as you
land so nothing's changed there but
after killing him with the revive after
that's done he drops his dagger for
everyone to access and now you can have
all of the princes feats at the negative
of course of you losing your current
heroes feats but let's be fair you don't
care about that now you yourself can
become the prince and tier 1 an entire
group of people and then tier 4 them
with the spears of fate and kill the
entire opposing team making them leave
hate mail in your inbox you have about
the same exact health as you would with
the hammer of Ragnarok but you can regen
it with the capture points now you don't
technically use the dagger I'm pretty
sure you just put it in you and but a
bunch of the people notice who you are
because just like the hammer of Ragnarok
there's some type of glowy kind of stuff
around you to symbolize that you're the
carrier of the dagger so that they
should keep aware of that so just keep
that in mind you are gonna be losing
your feats but you'll still be playing
pretty much like how the Prince is a
super T&D a normal T on D with just
really cool feats yours is going to be
super and then insert hero name so super
shaman and super Highlander pretty much
like that and of course once you die the
dagger is dropped
now I actually grin into a bit of an
issue as soon as I died the dagger
dropped and then immediately went back
to the Prince respawning I'm unsure if
the if that was just a coincidence or as
soon as you die the Prince comes back
but I'm going to assume that once you
died the dagger is dropped and then
within a certain amount of time the
prince will eventually respawn which is
why you can keep this as we're seeing in
the gameplay now I tried to see how long
I could keep with me possibly keeping
her for the entire
game and the prince took it from me when
he spawn back so definitely spend those
feats before time runs out because
you're definitely gonna want to use them
as usual for the game mode and trying to
win it it's a usual 150 points for
killing the Prince then you have to get
a thousand to break the enemy and kill
them just like normal ruler of time of
course only this time you now have the
dagger to use and that guy's is going to
be the chapter 2 overview of the blades
of Persia let me know what you guys
think about this in the comments below I
think this is gonna be fantastic I'm
honestly not a big fan of the Prince in
some certain situations especially when
he likes to spam the feats but I think
the Prince besides that is a fantastic
character and I'm super excited to see
what's gonna be happening to other
players and other lobbies when actual
players get their hands on this item and
they aren't just fighting BOTS like how
you're gonna be seeing in the gameplay
in a second yeah let me know your first
immediate thoughts about this in the
comments below but what that like to be
if you do enjoy guys subscriber if I
knew I covered the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates to the patch notes in
the leaks if you want to be kept in
today with everything happening within
the world of Warner and never miss out
and an update definitely stay subscribe
the channel
and what that guy's enjoy some of the
gameplay I recorded with my first
impressions of me actually playing for
the very first time with that take care
guys
peace out have a good day well goodbye
says respawn time is so I think they
just spawned it automatically that's
nice you get to actually keep his it's
just a normal game of ruler of time
except now instead of just killing the
Prince and having him be a nuisance who
could keep his stuff and even keep your
teammates alive and practically just
keep it the whole game that's fantastic
all right now we're gonna definitely at
this win while we're here and we might
as well I don't know how the hell we're
gonna kill the Prince here remind we
killed the Prince I'm just gonna shut up
my dagger excuse me
want to see a bot used one of us one of
these things
it's flashing I don't know if that's a
going away or if that's just like a
thing that it's it's for a visual effect
maybe it's a visual effect I hope it
doesn't disappear after sometime to be
kind of brutal yeah putting this on a
character that's busted good
oh it's game over it doesn't seem to be
any damaged books of any sort just seems
to be just like how the the technically
the prince is just the tea on tea with
buffs that's pretty much like like a
super tea on D now I'm basically a super
shaman in the in a sense I guess don't
you [ __ ] dare buddy that's mine
marciela fight somebody with this maybe
kind of quarter see this kind of scary
that does a lot of damage oh my god how
are we breaking bro what game what are
we doing team's slacking right now
unbelievable alright dude can I regen
hell I can regen health alright as long
as I'm in an objective I can regen
health that's really nice it's super
useful actually
excuse me
all right we're winning this game I
refuse to lose the game against bots
dude I have a reputation to uphold here
so it just locks on the nearest person
hi-yah
Oh what the [ __ ] okay so there's a time
limit I can't keep all right so you
can't keep this for the whole game all
right interesting so if you don't so you
should definitely use up as many
abilities as you can as quick as you can
cuz then the prince just takes it from
you all right that's good to know I
thought I was gonna keep that forever
that's good
it's kind of annoying
ah we're not losing this game [ __ ] that
let's go hate him
let's go to
all right well hold on hold on a minute
bots are all kind of confused their AI
is bugging out they don't know what's
happening
that's the dub easy does it
all right nothing this is a really fun
game mode yeah but they're guys that's
gonna be the end of the video hope you
guys did enjoy it like I said I've
already done the Oxford before but as
you could check the link down in the
description down below two more learn
and learn a bunch of stuff of what's
happening with the ruler time game mode
to keep you guys up to speed and as
always thank you be soft for sponsoring
today's video and that guys lick to be
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I cover the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes and the
leaks but that have a great yesterday
you know that good stuff and take care
[Music]
you
[Music]